good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight so did you take a moment
from your busy life to
turn on the hearings on capitol hill
today with the silicon valley ceos
don't be embarrassed if you didn't you
probably didn't no matter how worried
you are about big tech and obviously you
should be
gravely concerned you may have decided
to skip today's spectacle and
fold the laundry or call your in-laws
instead and we don't judge you for that
previous hearings on big tech have not
produced a lot elderly senators who
can't manage to send their own text
messages
wagging their fingers in the face of
sneering sneering billionaire tech
oligarchs from san francisco
all of whom seem to understand that no
matter what happens inside the hearing
room
they'll get to continue doing whatever
they want to do because they've got all
the money
we've seen that a number of times it
seems pointless in fact it seems
insulting
to the rest of us and in the end today's
hearings may prove
just as pointless we'll find out but for
one brief
moment today you got the feeling that
maybe actual progress
was being made maybe the good guys might
not be entirely lame
that moment came when senator josh
hawley asked mark zuckerberg the ceo of
facebook
about an internal tool that his company
has developed called sentra
holly knew about centra because a
whistleblower told them they told them
how it works
facebook employees use centra to spy on
users even when those users are not
using
facebook centra gives facebook access to
troves of personal data
including the pages users visit and the
accounts they have linked to facebook
you didn't know about this because all
of it happens in secret it's probably
not even legal
so today at the hearings josh hawley
confronted mark zuckerberg about this
and here's how it went centra is a tool
that facebook uses to track its users
not just
on facebook but across the entire
internet
center tax different profiles that a
user visits
their message recipients their linked
accounts the pages they visit around the
web
mr zuckerberg how many accounts in the
united states have been subject to
review and shut down through centro
senator i do not know because i'm not
actually familiar with the name of that
tool i'm sure that we
have tools that help us with our
platform and community integrity work
um but i am not familiar with that name
do you have a tool that does exactly
what i've described and that you can see
here
over my shoulder or are you saying that
that doesn't exist
senator i i'm saying that i'm not
familiar with it
i'm not familiar with it senator but
hold on a second mark zuckerberg you
run the company you started it and
centra sounds like a pretty big deal
are you saying that centra doesn't exist
well no
it turns out that's not what they're
saying just hours ago a facebook
spokesperson admitted to fox news that
centra is indeed real
and according to that spokesperson
centra is quote used to centralize
and aid investigations into complex
subjects like coordinated inauthentic
behavior and quote
coordinated into authentic behavior hard
to pronounce you may never have heard of
it
it's otherwise known as astroturfing
that's the process of creating fake
grassroots political movements sometimes
by foreign governments
it's something the left claims to be
very concerned about
in other words centra is yet another
long-term consequence
of the russia hoax so adam schiff gets
hysterical about vladimir putin
and then facebook gets to spy on you
without your knowledge and then sell the
data they gather
perfect but somehow mark zuckerberg who
runs the company said he had no idea
what was going on
and central wasn't the only secret
internal data gathering tool that
zuckerberg claimed to be ignorant of
senator hawley also asked him about
another internal facebook program called
tasks according to senator hawley's
whistleblowers
tasks allows facebook's censorship teams
to quote communicate with their
counterparts at twitter and google
and then enter those companies
suggestions for censorship
onto the task platform so that facebook
can then follow up with them
and effectively coordinate their
censorship efforts
got that they're all in it together
the tech companies amount to a
censorship cartel
mark zuckerberg did not deny this
instead he conceded it would be
quote probably pretty normal for people
to talk to their peers in the industry
and so yes it is all real silicon valley
acts as one the tech oligarchs joined
forces to censor their political
opponents
you may be one of them you weren't being
paranoid to worry about this
you were absolutely right is the hair on
your arm standing up yet
chris coons isn't worried he was
thrilled to hear it he wants more
coons is a senator from delaware he's a
former joe biden staffer actually
the press routinely describes chris
coons as moderate
not because of what he says but because
of how he says it
chris coons is boring therefore he must
be reasonable
that's the thinking but in fact chris
coons is not reasonable he is a power
hungry lunatic
who doesn't believe in the first
amendment of course chris coons went to
yale law school
ever notice how no one who went to yale
law school acknowledges the bill of
rights
what's their constitutional law class
like at yale law school we should find
out
watch chris coons push mark zuckerberg
in the hearings today
for even more censorship according to
chris coons there's not enough
you do mr dorsey have um policies
against
deep fakes or manipulated media against
covet 19 misinformation against things
that violate civic integrity but
you don't have a standalone climate
change misinformation policy
why not helping to disseminate climate
denialism in my view
further facilitates and accelerates one
of the greatest existential threats to
our world
so that was to jack dorsey who runs
twitter and chris coons's point was
really simple people who disagree with
chris coons are quote an existential
threat to our world
they must be silenced so who are these
people that chris coons doesn't believe
should be allowed to speak in public
well plenty of them would be
credentialed scientists who might have
legitimate questions about chris coons's
global warming theories
chris coons is a lawyer who spent the
last 20 years in government
everything he knows about climate he
learned from an issue of the atlantic
magazine he picked up at the airport
newsstand
chris coons is a non-expert if there
ever was one
but under the standard he is demanding
and demanded today in congress
the social media monopolies would censor
anyone who questions his shallow silly
views on one of the most complex areas
of known science
that is not a moderate position it is
authoritarianism
and there's a huge cost to the rest of
us this is censorship
censorship doesn't simply kill
expression though it does
censorship kills thinking and innovation
and wisdom
censorship inexorably leads to
self-censorship
people quickly learn what they're
allowed to express and what they're
allowed to believe
and so they stopped asking questions
even of themselves
their minds become narrower they stop
creating
art dies banality takes its place
science which depends on free inquiry
becomes impossible does that sound
familiar to you
it's where we are right now but that's
not a problem for people like chris
coons
his main concern is how to control an
inquisitive population
kuz would be delighted with a country
that cannot think for itself
a nation of passive consumers that takes
its orders from tech oligarchs and
quants in the finance world
shut up and obey or we will make you be
quiet
that's the message they're sending
collectively
a lot of us expected something different
to happen the election is over
the billionaire party got what it wanted
so why can't they take the boot off our
neck
no chance they're just getting started
in the past two weeks corporate america
has rushed to consolidate its control
over information and dissent in this
country we could give you countless
examples of that here are a few
the email delivery service mailchimp
announced it is refusing to provide
service email to the northern virginia
tea party
why the company cites potential
misinformation
it turns out the tea party had attempted
to notify its members
about a recount rally by email but
that's not allowed anymore
mailchimp banned them along with other
conservative organizations they're not
allowed to use email
paypal and airbnb have done the same
thing they've taken out accounts
belonging to conservatives
because they don't like the message but
the message they're sending
is really simple if you want to live a
normal life here
send an email transfer money rent an
apartment you had better be on the right
side
how is that different from what happens
in china call us and let us know if you
can spot the difference we can
abigail schreier who we talked to
yesterday on the show got an unexpected
phd in political repression recently
amazon cut off advertisements for her
book
the book's on the huge spike in
transgender identification among teenage
girls it's a real thing
she wanted to know why it was happening
so she tried to explain it but that's
not allowed
target banned your book completely for a
time a lawyer at the aclu which of
course used to defend
civil liberties cheered that decision
and said the book should be burned
meanwhile in a story very few saw a
major video game company ubisoft
erased a voice actor called helen lewis
from one of its titles
retroactively they erased her from the
picture as the soviets once did
what was her crime well she wrote a
forum post that anonymous people on the
internet felt was transphobic
and so for that ubisoft decided that she
should never work again
anywhere even her voice was too
offensive for the rest of us to hear
the mob then went to work trying to
destroy gina carano she's an actress who
plays a character called cara dune
in the tv series the mandalorian when
she criticized
mask mandates and quote preferred
pronouns
they decided she needed to be fired
where's this coming from
almost nobody likes it almost no
american
supports it corporations are behind it
all of it and the point is not to help
anyone much less you
let's be clear about that the point is
to establish control
they know that they can dictate what you
have the right to say about
trans rights or mass mandates they can
dictate what you can say
about anything that's unprecedented
power
no one in this country has ever had that
power our constitution used to prevent
it
but they have it now and that power will
come in handy when they're running the
government
which they may soon be take a look at
the people joe biden wants to install in
the white house in january
so far biden has hired a former
pharmaceutical and insurance industry
lobbyist called steve for shetty to be
his chief counselor
he's hired a venture capital executive
with close ties to big tech called ron
clayne to be his chief of staff
biden's deputy chief of staff apparently
will be a woman called jen o'malley
dylan
she co-founded a consulting company that
represented big pharma
biden also we learned today is bringing
on louisiana lawmaker cedric richmond
richmond has been a reliable ally of the
fossil fuel industry which by the way is
quite political these days and not
conservative time to
update your perceptions on that richmond
has received more money from the oil and
gas industry than virtually anyone else
in congress
so corporations are getting more control
and once they run everything they will
control what you say
what does that leave the politicians and
the career bureaucrats well it leaves
them free to play the role of petty
tyrant of course something that they
have always wanted fulfilling their
personal desires to impose their will on
the rest of us
in the state of michigan the poor people
who live there learned governor whitmer
relishes telling her constituents
whether they can hold
thanksgiving dinner and if they do she
said on sunday
they're essentially killing people
if you are considering spending
thanksgiving with people
outside of your household i urge you
to reconsider and i hate to say it but
we know that some people will gather
anyway
and odds are that some of these
gatherings will spread covet
and contribute to the loss of loved ones
oh i hate to say it well there's the
falses phrase ever uttered by an
american politician hate to say she
doesn't hate to say it
she's been saying it all year in april
governor whitmer banned the sale of
paint
and furniture what scientists told her
to do that
none she did it because she could now
she's banning thanksgiving what next
and that's not a rhetorical question by
the way this is more than a slippery
slope we're watching it happen in real
time
at a press conference yesterday the
governor of california gavin newsom
emphasized the most important thing here
you need to stay isolated now he doesn't
gavin newsome went to a private birthday
party with a dozen people the other day
at the french laundry in napa
but it turns out he wasn't breaking the
rules when he did that no he wasn't
settle down
he was just giving you an example of
what not to do
gavin newsom was risking his life for
you he's a covid martyr
why doesn't anyone appreciate gavin
newsom but again
that's immaterial we want to restate
here the important thing the essence of
science really
is that you spend the holidays alone
but i'll remind you that three-pronged
approach pre-vaccine was around
prevention testing and isolation
isolation this is profoundly important
prevention is one thing
testing what's the purpose of testing
besides obviously identifying people
that are positive and
building a framework and protocol to
protect their health but also
protect others through isolation and
quarantine
there's a lot coming at us right now but
take three steps back
pause ask yourself what are we really
watching we're watching something pretty
dark
honestly this isn't the politics
we've come to understand in this country
this isn't the usual debate about
tax rates or tariff policy we miss those
debates
this is a struggle for the fundamentals
will this remain a free country can you
disagree with corporate america and
still live here
we'd be allowed to fly on an airplane
stay in a hotel have a credit card use
email will tiny brain napoleons like
chris coons
determine what science is and what you
can say about it
or not that's what's on the table right
now
we understand we just had an election we
understand it's in dispute we understand
there's a lot of news going on at this
moment
but nothing matters more than this it
will decide the future